bientôt ces stagiaires seront confrontés
à la réalité du terrain tous
professionnels de la sécurité
ils seront peut être amenés à agir dans
des situations d'extrême tension en
france sont plus de 350000 agressions
recensées entre janvier et juin 2021 une
violence qui poussent de plus en plus
d'entreprises à faire appel à des agents
de sécurité hautement qualifiés je
voulais faire la formation pour avoir
une plus value à la fois sur mon cv est
à la fois personnellement pour apprendre
d'autres choses au niveau de la sécurité
ces déformations qui n'existait pas
avant qu'ils soient mis en place
récemment et c'est par rapport à la
demande de nos clients ici c'est une
simulation d'attaqué au couteau la
tension est à son comble
mais la maîtrise est nécessaire info
geste et tout peut basculer dans la peau
du méchant frédéric mathonnat 30 ans lui
c'est le redman il porte une combinaison
de 10 kg alors le redman glace et du
coup un agresseur mais qui va aller au
contact c'est à dire qu'avec la
protection redman ça vient de la couleur
je vais pouvoir prendre des coups je
vais pouvoir aller au sol elle est
beaucoup plus libre dans mes actions par
rapport à la violence des couples
l'agresseur ou le défendeur va mettre du
coup c'est par rapport à ça voilà le
redman le fondateur de l'école lui même
ancien professionnel de la sécurité
constate à quel point il est nécessaire
de mieux préparer les agents notamment
faisant appel à des enseignements
nouveau ils ont eu des coups aussi sur
le gestion de stress cela m'a dit à sion
il constate également l'importance du
rôle des agents de sécurité dans la
société nous avons vu avec l'aco vide
que
les
les emplois le mois qualifiant sont le
plus indispensables dans des grandes qui
lisent pas ce que parce que
vu des scènes de chaos en fait les gens
qui sont battus pour des papiers
toilettes je suis désolé donc les cent
et cent des agents de sécurité en fait
ça a été impossible de maintenir
maintenir l'ordre pour conclure ce stage
de perfectionnement une star de youtube
gérad nikara est venu motiver les
troupes moi j'ai toujours été dans les
sports de combat depuis l'âge de 5 ans
il envoie l'a ensuite à l'armée à la
légion étrangère j'ai continué dans les
sports de combat et j'étais athlète de
haut niveau en
judo en huit heures ou boxe pieds-poings
très apprécié dans le milieu de la
sécurité et des sports de combat ces
vidéos cumul des millions de vues cette
médiatisation apporte une image beaucoup
plus positive à ce secteur en france on
dénombre environ si l'établissement de
sécurité privée et 20000 salariers un
marché qui pèse près de 30 milliards
d'euros